today we're going to make a drink called
the boulevardier which is a variation on
the Negroni using bourbon instead of gin
I love new bronies and variations on
them because they utilize bitterness has
a primary flavor component in food
bitterness is usually thought of as a
negative quality but in cocktails is
just another dimension of flavor
this drink is super easy to make you
only need three ingredients bourbon
bitter Italian liqueur and sweet
vermouth so we're going to combine all
our ingredients in a mixing glass first
starting with the Bourbon ounce and a
half one ounce of bitter The Cure and
one ounce of sweet vermouth it's
important to combine all your
ingredients first before you add in the
ice if you build a drink with ice
already in here it'll start to melt and
over dilute the drink now we've got our
and grant behind we can add our ice and
we're going to stir this cocktail drinks
with all alcoholic based ingredients
like this one it should always be
stirred because it educates the ice less
and gives the drink is smoother silky
texture which is perfect for stiffer
sipping cocktails like this one all set
there now we're going to strain this
into a rocks glass over fresh ice the
ice we've been stirring with has already
started to melt so we want to strain
over fresh ice because this ice will
melt slower which will keep your drink
colder for longer
finally we're going to garnish with an
orange peel peel a nice swath and
express the oils over the top and there
you have it
so next time you're in the mood for a
strong sipping cocktail but you want
something a little more complex than
just whisky on the rocks go for a
boulevardier trust me you will not be
sorry if you like that drink subscribe
to the GQ channel for more